and there's also water there too good
afternoon
I had a feeling if we put on an event
even if it was a four o'clock in the
afternoon on a Monday a lot of people
would turn out in August I'm Bradley
Graham I'm the co-owner of politics and
prose along with my wife Lissa Muscatine
and on behalf of the entire staff thank
you very much for coming a few quick
administrative notes now would be a good
time to turn off your cellphone's or
anything the mic go beep when we get to
the QA part of the session we have one
microphone stand there and we'd ask if
you have a question please step up to it
a c-span book TV is here so and we're
also recording and we'd like to be able
to pick up your your question on on the
tape and at the end of the of the
session normally we ask people they all
used to fold up their chairs but don't
do that this time
just leave them where they are and just
form a line to the right of the table
and snake it back there out to the
street or you know being being very
helpful we hear it at PMP once ended up
in a doonesbury cartoon on a January
January morning several years ago we
awoke to find this store I mentioned in
passing as the location for a book
signing by one of the characters
naturally we were thrilled and and
relatives and friends from around the
country congratulated us on having
reached this pinnacle of Fame because
one hasn't really arrived until one
score is at least the reference in
Dewsbury by that measure Donald Trump
hasn't just arrived he's he's virtually
taken up residence in doonesbury a
dating back to the fall of 1987 when
Gary Trudeau started mocking what turned
out to be Trump's first presidential
trial balloon it wasn't long before that
the
and it wasn't long before the
unflattering portraits got under Trump's
thin skin and he tried as he's want to
do he tried striking back at Gary
a-calling dudes very overrated or
asserting the most people just don't
comprehend the strip for for his part
Gary Gary Gary just couldn't resist as
he says in the precipice of his new book
to have ignored Trump would have been
comedy malpractice the new the book
titled huge compiles three decades of
Doonesbury strips featuring Trump the
drawings made clear that over the past
30 years much about Trump hasn't
actually changed but as Gary told The
Washington Post in a recent interview
what he once regarded as harmless
buffoonery is in fact now dangerously
symptomatic just a few brief
biographical facts I do is Barry started
appearing 46 years ago growing out of
the the bold tales strip that Gary drew
at Yale in 1975 he became the first
comic strip artist to win a Pulitzer and
he's been appealing sir finalists
several times since he's also won
numerous other awards work in theater
and TV and been called the most
influential editorial cartoonist of his
time so ladies and gentlemen please join
me in welcoming Gary Trudeau
[Applause]
those of you who come here and here most
authors speak the art this it's not is
it's not on I'll speak a little louder
until I don't want to it's on all right
most of you who are regulars here are
accustomed to hearing authors read from
their books I promise you that would not
be a treat in my case reading comic
strips is a pretty hard thing to do so
what I thought I would do instead is
I'll read the preface from the book and
explain to you how I came to have this
peculiar relationship with with mr.
Trump the book is not my idea it was my
wife's idea we were having dinner a few
a few months ago and she said you've
done an awful lot on him there might be
enough over the last three decades and
so we scrambled and my good publisher
got the book out very quickly and anyway
so so what I'm going to do is just read
you the preface and after that I might
be happy to have a conversation with you
just to answer your questions so the
preference is begins with one of the
quotes on the back these are selected
comments from Donald Trump it's a
carefully curated collection of insults
that he has thrown my way over the years
so the one that I begin with a
third-rate talent trying to get
publicity on my back
his message conveyed through the
tabloids boiled down to this get off my
cloud loser which is not of course have
satire works the target having set
himself up doesn't get a say over the
incoming besides Trump had already
become the gold standard for big honking
hubris and to ignore him would have been
comedy malpractice in New York City he
practically owned the 80s rocketing to
the top as the Big Apple's loudest in
most visible [ __ ]
knock knocking off big league rivals
like Ed Koch Julian Schnabel and Steve
Rubell to those of us in the ridicule
the industry
the man's spy dubbed as the short
fingered Bulgarian was a gift beyond
imagining and we made him a permanent
part of our business plans their
earliest strips mocking Trump's first
presidential trial balloon began in the
fall of 1987 people tell me I should be
flattered Trump told Newsweek but as
there was nothing remotely flattering
about the portrayal he soon became
confused then irritated all the mores I
was drawing him in a way that suggested
I was unaware of how good-looking he was
by the end of the week it was game on
Trump had someone new to weigh along and
I had a new recurring character one
whose real life counterpart could be
counted on to react in real time I was
one lucky tar-baby and remained so for
years of course I've had plenty of
company googled Trump and third-rate and
you'll come across the names of most of
the country's first-rate comedians and
no matter how many wiseguys wanted a
piece of him there was always more than
enough of the big fella to go around an
embarrassment of Follies after that
first presidential head fake there was
the Trump princess a luxury yacht whose
owners fear of ocean travel kept it
moored off his various failing casinos
then came the extramarital affairs both
real and imagined conducted under klieg
lights followed in rapid succession by
the high-profile bankruptcies his
attempts to tear down a family
restaurant to build a parking lot for
limos his various televised televised
spectacles the most story - which
featured him firing celebrities who were
already out of work his his creepy
sexual fantasies about his own daughter
- the truth or duck debacle his failed
product lines and on and on like you
wouldn't believe
but the best was yet to come as Trent
bore down on his 70th year he needed a
new neighborhood to ruin so after 30
years of lusting after a certain tear
down on 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
he made good on his threat and actually
ran for president tan rested and ready
not so much more like orange hyperactive
and breathtakingly unprepared when his
physician Harold Bernstein declared the
Trump would be the healthiest individual
ever elected to the presidency Trump
publicly thanked jacob bernstein his
doctor's father who'd been dead since
2010 you can't make this stuff up so why
try some people feel that Trump is
beyond satire but we professionals know
E is satire pure and uncut free for all
to use and enjoy and for that we are not
ungrateful for our country though we can
only weep so the rest of it is is just
cartoons which I will spare you the
reading of but I'd be happy to to take
any of your any of your questions
yeah thank you
this is like a gift to us I just have
two quick questions they're not very
deep or well thought out
one is how recent are the cartoons are
they up to this like crazy time they go
up to the end of the April so they're
the most recent half dozen when you
wouldn't appear okay and I'm not Charlie
I'm gonna hold on to those for another
prisoners oh thank you okay I wanted to
thank you for all your great work and
particularly some of the strips that you
did that most resonated with me we're on
the importance of voting rights and
given the intersection of the danger of
a trump presidency and limitations on
voting rights I'm wondering if you can
comment on whether you have future plans
to work in this area I do and you will
see a Sunday coming up in the next
couple weeks about voting rights and I
have a character named Jimmy crow he's a
big fat crow and and he's ecstatic by
the developments in the country over the
last four years but they're being rolled
back and there have been a number of
Court decisions in stayed on the state
level that had been rolling back some of
these laws and hopefully enough of them
by November so that it wouldn't be there
wouldn't be any significant impact but
no we can't let that disappear as an
issue hi thank you my question is do you
believe that Trump will or won't win and
what is your reason
well I believe you won't win and but
like everybody else
I checked 538 about every half-hour you
just I just can't feel secure enough at
one point he had a 97% chance of losing
and that's all uncomfortable there but
now it's down to 80 point three and in
the end nate silver's I mean I admire
the guy but I can't nate silver who's
the genius behind 538 but I'd like not
to have to check every half-hour and so
I'm looking forward to November November
second five thirty eight.com is a
website that was founded by a young man
named Nate Silver who has started out as
a Moneyball guy as sports data analyst
and has become our premiere analyst of
of polls and he aggregates all the polls
and uses rather sophisticated models and
algorithms to pull together what the
odds are he calculates from three ways
if the boat were today if you're just
looking at polls how what the outcome
would be in November and the third
factors in history and trends from
previous elections and the vote today is
the most encouraging
that's almost 81 percent but the odds of
him winning of Hillary winning decreased
to about 73 percent if you factor in
history if you will yeah you've been at
this for 46 years half century you know
yeah um are there any parallels to trump
in your memory no and certainly not in
the way that that I have used him in the
strip he is the only character that he's
not actually a parody I just lifted him
from real life and he is he is a kind of
natural-born tune he
I like to compare him to Daffy Duck the
self regard and the language issues and
constantly stepping on his own feet but
yeah I took him right out of the box
took the labels off and put him right in
the strip and the other the other
characters regarding is sort of a
colleague and there are 12 I think
characters who interact with him I think
it would get pretty hard to go through a
whole book if it was just all focus on
him so it's how he interacts with all my
other characters it's the only person
from public life I've ever done that
with my character I do very little
caricature per se but the hair is of
course irresistible and somebody in mind
in my business has just just catnip and
I go way back with that here I go back
to when it was brown and then it kind of
lightened up and then he set it on fire
to run for president and it's just this
a gilded confection that we see now so
that's kind of hard to stay away from if
you're if you're in my in my profession
yeah thanks very much welcome I really
love your work
but I will have to say that when I saw
the cover of your book even though I
love your work I was just so turned off
because I cannot stand that man but I
just want before I ask my question this
is a real quick one just to sure me I
did buy the book that none of my $15 or
whatever it was that I spent is going to
go not one penny to Donald J Trump
billionaire know there would be no
reason for that whatsoever you know I'd
like to say that millions and means and
means and have sold and that all of all
the money's going to veterans and the
poorly educated and but well it is going
to poor you probably go to my children I
mean he writes this himself
I you know he spent what the last two
weeks focusing on getting the
african-american vote
and saying that you know Hilary's a
bigot and all she cares about what the
african-americans is their vote and then
when we have a prominent
african-americans family member murdered
in Chicago he writes in on Twitter you
know you know you know he got murdered
vote Trump you know and and so it just
really kind of writes itself how do you
how do you keep it fresh when he is
doing these things himself well that's
sad I mean that that particular tweet
some of them are outrageous in different
ways and they're more fun to you know to
poke fun up that that one was just
tragic and I think even if not you know
I think he is kind of lives the kind of
empathy free life he doesn't seem to
have much humanity and so I think it
probably had to be explained to him why
that wasn't the way to go in response to
this this very terrible murder and you
know then the tweets get pulled down and
new ones go up and so obviously the
people around him maybe it maybes on
family members said you know dad that
that wasn't cold so yeah I mean that
doesn't that's probably not that doesn't
immediately give me an idea for sure
just because of the sad nature of it but
there's the political work you're
working and you know when David Plouffe
who was who I respect you know
completely called him a psychopath and
in the Morning Joe crew or calling him a
sociopath I would like to hear just real
quickly what which side you weigh yes
well I I think that you know that what
the book shows which I hope it shows is
that the the under the underlying
personality disorder has been remarkably
stable over 30 years and and it's a kind
of you know what what I originally
thought of as colorful harmless
behaviors turns out to be a cluster of
symptoms and we're more like a symphony
of symptoms you know with high notes of
mania and low notes of aggression and
all of them probably and dissonant I you
know I I am not a psychiatrist but
fortunately I'm a cartoon
so I can say those things without any
authority whatsoever it's but I do think
that the election is to anyone who
really thinks it through is it could
well be seen as a referendum on mental
health so I have a question but I want
to start out with a compliment - really
um we're contemporaries it kind of
upsets me that you're 20 years younger
than me since were the same age I think
that's because you are called Kunis and
I'm a sociologist that's one compliment
the other as a sociologist I just got to
say mostly for everyday but certainly
recently for every week it has just been
my pleasure to get educated to you and
entertain by you for all these years and
I think that's true for a lot of us all
thank you well I think for most people
in my business entertained you have to
put entertainment first and it didn't
really occur to me until a couple years
into into the work that I had this
extraordinary opportunity to move people
to thought and judgment about things
that I cared about whether I had the
tools to do that
they were pretty rudimentary in the
beginning I was not ready for prime time
player I think that I was probably
marketed I wasn't there but I'm pretty
sure I was marketed by the two really
smart guys who started my syndicate that
was their first feature as as I as a
insider to the counterculture I was 21
and the idea was oh he's a fanuc because
after all he's 21 he knows what's going
on in colleges and these weren't just
and these are dispatches from the front
and and so I think I got by a novelty
for those first five years or so and and
well yeah hope so hope so
but but I don't think you know people
were unaccustomed to seeing those issues
raised in their comics pages and editors
gave me a hard time in the beginning and
I got thrown out of papers for lack so
that went on for a long time
about 20 years but and continues to
occasionally but I have nothing but
respect for editors and what they do and
always defended them I never called it
censorship because I don't believe
that's what it was
each editor has has has the
responsibility to decide what goes in
their paper on any given day they had
the feel of their particular community I
can't pretend that I do of 600
communities for all those newspapers so
I always tried to back them up and
particularly in those early years when
you know I was still trying to figure
everything out I was I was I was new to
everything and when which was one of the
reasons that I stepped back from from
being a public figure to the degree that
anyone wanted me to be I stopped doing
interviews because every time I get
thrown out of the paper the paper would
send a reporter and they would want me
to defend the work well if you have that
many clients and you owe them all
something it gets to be an enormous
distraction and I thought it would be
better if I just focused on the work so
I didn't do any interviews for many many
years and that had this Sun you know
this one unanticipated benefit of that
was it is the strict took on a kind of
mystique that I don't feel responsible
for it's just that it's just that oh
yeah he's this mysterious figure who
does this thing and we don't know
anything about him and that may have
given me a longer half-life as an artist
both endures me personally but also in
terms of the public's you know they
didn't have to put up with me on The
Tonight Show every comment I find you go
from Walt Kelly who you know but
whoo-hoo-hoo
during his similar times during the
McCarthy era willed an entire sequence
of nothing but love and bunny wabbits
yeah he called him the bunny robber
seriously and the editors had them in
their hip pockets they were you know
they were allowed to use them whenever
they wanted and I think he we didn't do
that
we said come on either run it or don't
and
you know often often there would be you
know local reasons why they couldn't run
it when I wrote about Jerry Brown his
associations with mob when he was
governor in in the 70s the it was
knocked out of virtually I think every
California paper plus Reno plus Las
Vegas and nowhere else in the country so
those are editors responding somewhat
dishonorably to regional pressures or
you know local pressure but my question
is Trump except for the issue two very
important issues of race and immigration
Trump is actually more liberal on almost
every position than the other Republican
candidates were when he is different
seems to me in style and rhetoric and so
I'm wondering and I hope after his
hopefully failed candidacy that you will
I wonder if you agree I mean some of the
what these other Republicans from you
know the senator from Mississippi who
loved Ron thermal on his hundredth
birthday and said you were right in 1948
I mean these are serious Republican
positions that are much worse than
Trump's we wonder if you have any
comments on them well Trump isn't going
away obviously and he's got all the
pieces in places should he want to
create a media empire after after he
leaves but as far as as him I do think
he sued generis I do think he is he's
he's not replicable in any way and that
there will be people who might take some
of those positions but I it's all
personality it's all emotion it's all
what he can do when he stands in front
of a crowd which is why so insecure when
he's not standing in front of a crowd he
bragged to a crowd I don't have to stand
in front I don't have to talk to two
people when I can have 12,000 well
talking to two people generally implies
listening he is not to my knowledge
sat down in a kitchen table he is not
sat down at a barbecue bench he's not
done any of the things that that
candidates do everyone's forgot about
Hillary Clinton was listening to her she
just went and listened all over our
state and I'm in New Yorker and you
can't imagine what that meant to people
in upstate New York where I'm from
up in the Adirondacks and I he has no
interest in that piece of it 12,000
people in the aggregate sure that's
that's something because they're all
cheering him and they're all repeating
his one one-liners but the thing about
Trump's fans that kind of mystifies me
the ones who love him don't seem to
comprehend that he doesn't love them
back he has no interest in their
problems he just happened to have have
through design or through accident have
landed on some positions that matter
deeply to him to them but it's it's not
reciprocated he you know he walks off
the stage little squirt of Perel he's
back on the jet and he's back in the
penthouse you got it so what exactly
inspired you to start writing cartoons
well the question case anyone didn't
hear it was what inspired me to start
writing cartoons there was an individual
who inspired me he was a football player
and did my college and he was very very
talented on the field he could he was
extraordinary and had a lot of charisma
and everybody loved him and his team's
never lost games year after year so I
thought well maybe I'll ride his
coattails that's a sort of interesting
story now he was a very modest
self-effacing man named Brian Dowling
who went on and had a had a career in
professional football and his teammates
respect him enormous ly I decided to
flip that on its head and have him be
this egotistical you know authoritarian
quarterback who everybody in the huddle
pushes back against him so that was the
idea was the tension I never actually
drew them throwing footballs there was
but it was a sports trip and it was a
one-off and the team he was going to
graduate and that was going to be the
end of it I've been doing it for about
three weeks when
syndicate a new syndicate head founded
in the my college newspaper and offered
me my current job this is a story my
kids hate if it doesn't involve any dues
parent paying it doesn't seemingly
involve any preparation it doesn't
involve any obvious skillset and it just
happened and now you do have to prepare
yourself too you have to place yourself
in the way of good fortune and there are
things that if I really you know win
back my childhood there are things that
got me there that got me to that place
nonetheless it's mostly an accident that
you know I'm here that you're here we
wrote a note to Donald Trump saying like
hey so people do not really like you
well I think you've performed your civic
duty for those over for the year yes sir
I'm wondering um after you stepped away
from from the strip did you always know
that if this event happened you're going
to have to come back there's no way you
could let it go well I am totally
stepped away from it a couple years ago
I got involved in television and I had I
had done things in the past but but not
as what they call the showrunner who's
who has to deal with everything and so I
called up my boss yes I have a boss yeah
and and said you know I really like this
you know what I'm doing this show and
how would you feel that if we split the
differences I don't retire but I did but
I do the Sundays so that I can work in
these and this other field and he was
you know I've been in harness for so
many years how could you say no so about
two years ago or two and a half years
ago I stepped away from the daily strips
and I still do the we call them classics
now there's their rerun
and I've added them pretty carefully to
remove as many as the you know the
really dated cultural references but
they are they are strips in the 80s that
are running right now except for the
Sundays which I love still doing and you
know I'm happy to and that I can fit
into my life and is there anything else
that might bring you back into a more
active role some others and Daffy Duck
ran for president you brought him up no
it's more what's going on in my life now
it's what's going on in the world
although I'm so happy that I am doing is
this particular time idk LRC's yeah
thank you hi I was wondering in all
these decades that you've been making
fun of Trump as he ever tried to contact
you phone you know he's just he's just
communicated through the tabloids and it
made his displeasure known I have never
met him I've seen him in the field and
it's it's something I was up at the New
Hampshire primary last January in the
newsroom when he came out after the
debate and he stopped in front of me and
turned around and so I was about four or
five feet away from the back of his head
okay and I could not take my eyes off it
it was it was the most remarkable thing
I'd ever seen it was it went it was like
a panel of gossamer had been had been
lacquered down with the kind of golden
slurry and it's that camera really
doesn't do it justice so if you ever get
a chance to see the back I mean the
front is gray in the front is fun to
draw because III don't know how many
other cartoonists do it quite the same
way but it's there's a there's a single
line you can draw that starts at the
temple and it heads back and then it
zooms forward under the ledge and then
heads back you know then it goes west
over the head and down and down into the
down into the collar and that's where I
start
you know with that with that line you
can you can see it here
starts here and so there yeah it's
fun2draw the guy well you're definitely
one of a kind you want sorely missed
that you ever do decide to retire I was
wondering do any of your kids share your
political bite for insight um its if
anything they're they're a little to the
left of their father especially my
daughter who was a country singer for a
while down in Nashville and now she's a
corporate law here what she just had she
just had a baby last winter and was home
with MSNBC for several months and
there's no other stuff I mean her brain
is like it's like shrubs been installed
in there like a big air horn and that's
also you can think about and talk about
right now my my other two none of them
have been are interested in cartooning
or in satire or my world but that's
pretty typical I think of a lot of kids
thank you very much
so I don't know if you know but I was
watching a Rachel Maddow a couple of
weeks ago and they she act she was very
excited about finding this clip of him
on the floor of the 88th convention
right I in the beginning of your forward
it's sort of the first part of well I'm
told I'm supposed to be flattered and he
clearly was completely baffled about how
he was supposed to think about it
because he was being paired he was being
in the center of the conversation but he
didn't really know even how to make that
it was I was lathering I was I mean that
was a fascinating clip it was a clip of
Chris Wallace on the floor of the 88
convention in which I believe was in New
Orleans every Republican convention and
which I was at and so he asked him this
question and then and then I got thrown
back to Tom Brokaw who was anchoring and
consolate well I just talked to Trudeau
and he had an encounter with Jeb Bush
and Bush and this is at the time when I
was depicting his father as putting his
manhood in a blind trust and this I was
not in a good odor with the Bush family
and and so Tom said that Jeb said to me
be kind and I and I wrote Tom right away
when I saw this clip on Rachael and I
said Tom my memory is awful and years is
extraordinary - is that what I told you
he said and he said and because what I
remember him saying and he's quite a
tall man he's like 6-3 6-4 he came up to
he looked down he said said Trudeau
walked softly well come on no that's
that's like you know that was that was
like go
and so yeah I was an interesting
convention but but Trump was I hadn't
seen that in 25 years it was it was fun
fun that she dug it out of the archives
well one of the comments I wanted to
make was the the fact that Trump is
going to have this really bizarre
presence in Washington DC on
Pennsylvania Avenue no matter what
transpires and I don't know if you're
aware that there's a big issue going on
right now about some FOIA requests and
now some lawsuits trying to determine
that it appears that the city of
Washington Washington DC and the
Department of Interior in the parks
department has given the Trump
Organization control of the part of
Pennsylvania Avenue in front of the
hotel as well as the plaza that has the
Ben Franklin statue which is a national
park area what do I mean by control
control like they can control traffic
and therefore potentially limit oh I got
to come down for that access thank you
for the heads yeah so I thought you
should know that there's fodder out
there whatever way this goes why don't I
take one more and then we'll get to book
signing I I so long time I've been a to
questions one when is the next season of
alpha house do we don't think there'll
be one which is which is the same out
they they actually ordered some new
episodes and we went in the writers room
and wrote him and started to plan for it
and then they called and said well we
changed our minds now I you're not going
to get me to say anything bad about
Amazon because I've had this
extraordinary opportunity to do two
seasons and it doesn't mean you get to
do a third but they are a black box
there's no you know annoying in all
things ask ask you know any anyone who
tries to find out what's happening
financially with that company it's
impossible and so they were all very
polite
they just said no we don't think so
anymore so yeah that was a bit of a blow
earlier this year okay well second
question mainly what do you what do you
think is going to happen to the
Republican Party after this like when it
win or lose it's going to this is
changing the ending them whatever
happens and I just I really don't know
what direction are they going to become
more like Trump or they try to distance
themselves I really don't know well
what's what's been remarkable about the
last week is that they is that through
now not just one splinter group of two
splinter groups and that the alt-right
has suddenly you know their their
message is being normalized by the day
and their spokespeople are now on the
radio and on television and how are they
going to get rid of that splinter it's
it's it's a I don't know I don't know
how they put themselves back together
after this I do think that they're I
don't think there's a movement I don't
think that there's a you know trumpism
exists I think Trump exists but I don't
like trumpism exist so they'll they'll
do it without the benefit of his
presence but a lot of what will depend
on how they how the races shake out in
November so all right
thank you so much very we have books for
sale in the back and we'll set up a sign
in line right now I just you know that
because it's a young man - hi - I get
these pieces paper
don't we